I just met a guy here who I thought he
wanted me to take a photo of him he
wanted to take a photo of me cuz he
apparently knows me what's your name
Zach Zach nice to meet you sorry you
this is this is I come to Switzerland
and I get recognized meaning I am a god
I'm a Killa Julie I think Zach would
agree I'm God status Thank You Zach I'm
ascared
you ready to go over the top I'm ready
to do this winner takes all loser picks
the ball this is for custody of my son
oh wow
yep son it's the plot of over-the-top
1987 all right good
well I'm doing the plot of the Danish
girl I'm the girl
I'm ready to go this is nice very test
professional service I've seen this
guy's beat one two three you're not even
truck I really tried
I let him win gave me that I let him
take me though
I'll take those good news mine you see
my testicles anyway
stop recording the man who was filming
this for us watch to film me getting
defeated he taught Smith the French
Deadpool vs candy crush all sugar video
it's an awesome man thanks great with a
great sense of humor thanks pretty girl
but and he also does have some chest
hair I have a little bit of just there
not as much as you maybe it's how we
party in Zurich that is the exact same
TV I have at home ok wait please
oh my god I love you I'm gonna do this
vr beast you are very excited right now
freaking out
and seen reactions that sounds beautiful
I'm excited created a VR experience
let's do this why reimagine
Wow I can't hear anything
but john-boy sirs talking [ __ ] about me
right now I'm at a menu I'm at the play
button
okay whoa
Helen's going on regarding your
traveling
well Todd never forgetting this
hello kid
I see yes
this is a giant play by a lot of stand
yeah
now guys watching porn on his laptop
right now whoa 600 miles per hour
today we're going over Berle Andy oh
they don't like me over there
shiny bird here
I'm in the clouds guys
for the clouds
he's starting a - been a fan over here
reject he claims himself what's her name
swen
swen welcome to the channel swim oh it
was a swim meet does I have a meaning
you look like a young warrior I could
see us battling each other one day so
you watch the channel sure sure sure
you're like an active watcher if you
only see me once then you're acting like
you've seen me before
I didn't know how loyal you are of a fan
swim he's a loyal fan Thank You swim
thank you for being here
come here bringing it bringing it he's a
good man white cat music
mature Americans over here
why